hello robert hello Benny you've arrived
at my household with the Box if I have a
bar because your house is a mess it is
actually I've had the flu for like the
last two or three days I know about you
guys but when Rob gets the flu
Rob's give a damn goes out the window
Benny's playing video games today I'm
calling duty all day now you get
whatever videos are just waiting to go
up at some point you get you get you get
Green Arrow rebirth island of scars
that's what you get that's not a video
that I would point out under a normal
circumstance like yeah that's that's not
you know I'm sick yeah and if anybody's
wondering are nbe still that way
yes this is the other side with the
window yeah we don't show the side the
action figures are very stands yeah yeah
this is not actually figures they're
statues they are adult collectible
they're do they're action figures
they're sighs she'll collect up their
statues nothing moves on those their
actions nothing moves action figures
have pauses and kungfu grips there are
action figures those are not action
figures those were action figures man
yes please tell me you saw seven okay
thank God I thought oh wait a minute
guys don't worry hey Ron will always
talk to whoever is watching the camera
from behind the camera okay it's
recording cool I I hit my my pocket I
want to make sure I was still recording
and I was like all say made me paranoid
technical difficulties okay so uh oh we
did get this box cut it all right I'm
going to put a get my so I'm gonna
assume that this is your giant pizza
stone yes all right so I ordered a great
big huge pizza stone see it's huge every
gonna make giant pizzas today there's
four extra large pizza is this for the
new show Rob cooks whatever he's in his
house yeah so this pizza will be made of
chicken noodle soup some bread baskets
sour patch kids
crackers
and some kool-aid so it's gonna be
what's the crest Rahab that's the crest
that's all we have is crust like this
it's gonna be a it's gonna be no this is
actually my 1 million subscriber plaque
from YouTube so I yeah I just realized I
can't say it but everything matches Oh
[ __ ] no I get that all the time
people you're like no way you lived
there and I'm like yes I do actually
ok so let's crack this open do it over
that side over there alright alright
hope the box wasn't precious yeah the
box is not precious about look at the
condition of this thing man Jesus stone
yeah for the pizza stone nobody cares
about the [ __ ] the pizza stone
what do you kick at your pizza on a
million subscriber yes congratulations
on a million subs everybody time to make
a pizza the cross this is like a million
subs with a pizza logo graduates come to
explain the rod congratulations
yeah yeah pizza that sound good ok Wow I
know I was there and I've had to look at
it every day but I come over here you
know we made sure one of the first
things we did was put that in position
where you could see it every day you
want it this is ok ok all right look ok
so here's a here's a box here's what it
comes in all right so it's it's black
and white like YouTube stance on d1
information you know some other time so
it's not feel cold hearted about it all
I'm just saying
all right can I read this oh I read it
after the day for you
yeah redrew matically yeah do that you
all bigger than Vancouver you're bigger
than Venice you're even bigger than Las
Vegas 1 million subscribers
maybe you've imagined
that day from a long time or maybe you
are maybe youth never thought you'd grow
so big
either way not much can match the
satisfaction of finding out that your
creativity your ID is being hampered by
D monetization your voice speaks to 1
million people across the globe yes it
says we know that being able to touch
the lives of so many people is reward
enough
but we're incredibly proud of all that
you've done so we hope that you'll
accept this gold creator a war that's a
token of our esteem hold on I have to
reread that because due to a misprint
that's like slanted so that would be a
little more like we know that being able
to touch the lives of so many people is
reward enough but we're proud of all
you've done
wolf it's slated your track record
we suspect that only go that you're only
going to keep growing we can't wait to
see you reach the next milestone 10
million subscribers that's not gonna
happen but yes it may seem far away but
remember the days when you were psyched
to have a thousand yes especially now
your you've amazed us keep dairy keep
dreaming keep creating you're the
inspiration for everything we do and we
shall do monetize everything you do
that's exactly what it does zooty this
with us
sincerely Susan which is constant with
Chomsky I would never call him a
champion
she's one of the people that made the
matrix she's like the third forgotten
member of the family okay fine I'll be
ready to open this up alright alright
yeah
Oh hail spells man leavened D monetize
the plaque look at that
well that's worthless baby monetize the
plaque yes it's D it's be monetize look
at that man that's a new reward that's
the new reward is you could deem on it
your plaque gets the monetize hold on a
pull the bag out so they can see this
okay yeah look at that it's D monetize
right there
Big D monetize my plaque thank you my
mate two new rewards makes sense I'll
tell you what yeah really glad I have
mine without that yeah well you know I
guess it kind of makes sense now yeah
it's actually not true guys I put this
on here I literally put it on sealed it
up and I was like dude Benny like we
have to unbox this for the D
monetization am I supposed to keep a
straight face the hole wakes up well you
know what's so bad about this is like
that's entirely possible you to the new
the whole new things are gonna come out
with these D monetization stickers on
them you got in a Rob core sticker right
here oh yeah I probably should have I'm
right or one cuz I got this from
vistaprint I might order one and then
just like stick it on Oh another
youtuber be inside yogurt yogurt even a
guy orders a what like a yellow dollar
signs circle thing yep he's a youtuber
making fun of YouTube so English
unboxing this is the speech mode where
you thank everyone oh yes okay um I
would like to thank myself for working
hard and getting myself to where I am
right now
Wow clearly none of the 1 million people
I'm being rewarded for did this no thank
you so much guys like seriously for
really for true this is this is nuts
like I'm not gonna lie no I wouldn't I
would not be I'm no I'm not gonna do
that head may want to comment down
I'm just saying man no no it all
seriousness when Benny and I started
college Louie taught a comic store and I
saw the commas displayed we never
thought we would see anything like this
you illegitimate we've told it it's
enough but he would make me mad cuz
we've gettin calls and he'd be like
Benny we're gonna hit a million subs and
I'd be like Rob that's impossible the
markets not big enough for that no would
be interested in that
yeah stop like getting like I was doing
with long how did the movie stuff going
on and you were like no we're gonna do
it just shut up let's do our jobs we're
getting my hopes up ya know you're quick
getting my hopes up and I'm like no man
if you believe you can achieve he was
that corny - I love those freezes man do
you have the cat poster like hey keep
hanging in there
oh no but I've seen that yes I love that
I love that so much you know you're
shrimper guys if you shoot for the moon
you won't make it to the moon but you'll
live among the stars
so you'll miss your destination but
you'll get something I knew a guy that
does get that same really be like that
saying makes no sense it's like no
because if you go to the moon you're
still in the stars but if you like that
doesn't make sense if you're going to
the moon you're going to the moon how do
you get to the stars the space with the
moon man yeah I mean it's not like
people are like hey man there we go it's
on the moon not with the stars because
the moon is not a star I mean I guess
that's true but you know I don't know
the point is always strive for breaking
yes I guess bring this stuff back
sideshows you took it out of the package
once before yeah yes my dog sheds so bad
currently Ginny gets second Max's
adoption to the back of this plaque yeah
it's it's Max's pad about shedding and
he'll just he'll just walk through the
house and just shake and it'll just be
hair everywhere it's like Jesus Christ
max maybe I was gonna take your place I
did see myself walking out with a whole
dog oh you'd walk out covered in here
yeah I can guaran-damn-tee you that like
I mean I go through it like vacuum like
every other day and it's not enough it's
like Jesus man so what are you where you
gonna put it uh I'm not sure yet
actually I mean I didn't put it right at
the injury I'm gonna do that actually
yeah I might do that because what I want
to do is I want to have like an office
in the partial basement so I might just
hang it up on the wall down there I
don't know but I'm gonna find a place to
put it on display
because because for the a lot of the
guys may not know like stuff like this
like I keep stuff like this like the
first meetup that you and I had was in
San Antonio or was in Texas or something
like that no it was in Dallas with Drake
oh yeah yeah and that was yeah we all
just hung out in a comic book store that
was it that that's what we first met um
Dylan I think yeah that was actually and
so honestly I missed those days when we
were big enough that people would show
up yeah but we weren't so big that we
could just plan it in a regular comic
book store yeah and we could that now if
people know we're gonna be somewhere
like if we say hey guys we're all gonna
be at Midtown comics like they'll be
people standing outside waiting again
they turned us down yeah Oh Midtown dude
yeah I don't even though we apply to be
a [ __ ] the first year that the weekly
poll is going down there this is when we
were kind of like the bigger rise board
oh yeah the week people so I asked him
to tell on us and they said that we were
too large of an entity to have in their
store really they didn't want to deal
with it during your comic-con that makes
sense yeah because they're already
dealing with everybody who's going there
they were polite about it for the record
guys do not attack me down comics they
were super didn't light about it like it
makes sense they seem like cool guys
yeah yeah but um no so so when we were
at that um we were at that fan meetup I
got a copy of a force number one from
the secret Wars which is the blank
variant cover and I had all my fans like
silent like I was like everybody was
there at that meeting I was like
everybody autograph this thing and it's
one of the coolest things that I have
like I literally keep it like in
pristine condition and that's one of the
things I'll put on display do you really
I thought about do an appeal box yeah
and getting thinner yeah I thought about
doing that but any of it guys so this
goes out to you guys thank you so much
for helping this channel grow to a
million subscribers I guess we should
take off the D monetization I'm just
trying to stay afloat oh yeah they don't
poke you with that right yeah it's not
making for a year that that won't have
your guys comments explain comics Torian
is shutting down for a year so I can
focus on art which elements
oh so you have a year to catch up yeah
never get caught up with her on YouTube
No
I guess man but like I mean Rob Rob
convinced me guys the Rob Court has shut
me down now dude twitch is the way the
future that's the future of video and
live-streaming
like that's the way that's going but
anyway guys yes thank you so much it is
awesome
so now like the Rob core is like 1.2
million strong right now so yeah thanks
to everybody like the old people like
the old fans who don't watch anymore the
old fans who still watch the new fans
who watch like anybody if you're a part
of my channel like thank you guys so
much and this is this is absolutely
amazing so